- C'est dans cette serre sur le
toit d'un ubububle d'Ahuntsic
que Lufa a récolté ses premiers
légumes il y a 10 ans.
Depuis, l'entreprise
en a aménagé trois autres :
une à Laval, une à Anjou
et une autre à St-Laurent.
Mais pour le fondateur, ce n'est
que le début de l'aventure.
MOHAMED HAGE, cofondateur
et coprésident, Les Fermes Lufa
- Notre vision, c'est de
développer un modèle qu'on peut
répliquer partout dans le monde,
mais on n'est pas encore là,
alors on a encore beaucoup
de travail à faire.
- Avec une superficie totale
de six terrains de football,
les serres Lufa produisent
plus de 25 000 kilos
de nourriture chaque semaine.
L'entreprise compte aujourd'hui
600 employés, dont Javier,
qui est là depuis le début.
- Je me sens vraiment "proud"!
(rires)
- Lufa, qui n'avait que
200 abonnés au départ,
livre maintenant plus
de 25 000 paniers chaque
semaine. L'entreprise a formé
des partenariats avec d'autres
producteurs pour diversifier
son offre et offrir une
véritable épicerie en ligne.
- Aujourd'hui, on est capables
de personnaliser tout le contenu
du panier. Et on a aussi
apporté plusieurucucucucteurs...
producteurs alimentaires
et maraîchers sur notre
plateforme web.
- Marie-Hélène Demers est
une fidèle cliente depuis
cinq ans. Elle a été conquise
par la philosophie de
l'entreprise et par
ses produits.
MARIE-HÉLÈNE DEMERS, cliente
- C'est des légumes frais,
c'est des aliments frais,
c'est local. La livraison
aiaiaiaiait par des voitures
électriques.
Mais tout est bio. Alors, pour
moi, c'est vraiment manger bio,
manger bien.
- Selon ce consulant, c'est
grâce au flair de son fondateur
que Lufa est devenue un succès.
ANDRÉ MICHAUD, président,
Agro Québec
- Il y avait définitivement un
besoin auprès des consommateurs
pour un concept comme celui-là.
- Et des projets,
Lufa en a bien d'autres.
L'entreprise veut s'implanter
aux États-Unis, avec l'ouvertur.
- Il y a beaucoup de similarités
entre Boston et Montréal.
C'est des villes qui sont
très àààààà l'innovation.
Alors, on voulait s'assurer
qu'on a quand même une bonne
chance de succès
dans notre première aventur
à l'extérieur du Québec.
- Lufa veut aussi poursuivre
son expansion au Québec.
Une autre serre sur toit verra
le jour dans le Grand Montréal.
Et il y a aussi un projet
spécial dans les car
tenu secret pour le moment.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréa